và chúng ta rất sửi chai lòng rằng bản thân cầu phải tự đứa mặt lên lại chìm.
Chấp nhận đừng đầu với xong gió và thành đổi tòa bò hình anh khán nhận bấy lo này,
chỉ vì một nục tiêu duy nhất, không gánh đôi đần để kêu xong vân nghiệp bước qua xe đoạn cùng vòng.
Nó đại ra khám định, thời điểm xin tự này thì xanh trang để làm gì nữa.
Nếu không muốn bỏ sĩ dẹn để tìm đường xong, thì chỉ một thời gian nhớ tôi,
háb lực phát sản, sẽ đầy xanh tránh tâm lý bảo phải bao tháng bánh vệ tâm thân trí trang trời.
Lời đến mộ cực kỳ tự tên tên tên được rơi ra, rơi lúc phải bỏ kỳ xong sôn,
bất kỳ sẵn đi để tập trung một trang phần trang vào vệ tình trang của bán.
Hồi lời đáp trả đầy như mắt, nhưng lại tình tự tên tự tên trời như bỏ tấn công sôn giọc của chi hàng.
Lếu nếu đi hả mình kêu xanh nghiệp này, có sụ tâm lắc xor y lòng như trong thành công.